[Music]
ah ready start why not Thank You Otto
kdramas became really popular before
kpop rolls to its prominence as we know
of it today I have a question are you
two Korean okay just want to make sure
it's very interesting to see how it
became a global phenomena Korean culture
is bringing a lot of different people
together regardless of ethnicity just
take a look outside of two times yes all
these people have beautiful people fans
play a huge role and Korean drama fans
tend to be extremely knowledgeable what
is a kdrama is a Korean drama is it all
in the Korean language yes we have
dramas are they different Korean dramas
in Korea used to be entertainment form
designed for housewives however that
notion is completely challenged nowadays
today we are doing a few scenes from
very popular K dramas my love from
another star the heirs and my
unfortunate boyfriend to show that we
can act
oh I notice that there are certain
tropes that you can't really escape when
you're watching a kdrama hey drama
cliches that people tend to identify
dramatic looks car accidents that result
in amnesia forgotten past that leads to
dangerous incest love story between poor
girl with a heart of gold and rich
handsome guy did enough well you've done
a stop they are recycled over and over
and over again or people tend to cling
to those stories to escape and just
forget about it all do people fall in
love and then their love complicates the
plot that's a good show how do they
fight in kicking them in the chest who
kicks people the judge hey keya are you
you shut up I can't see I'm blinded what
are they doing kdramas them that's funny
accidentally on each other
oh hey drama comedies are like slapstick
yeah excuse me excuse me can you move
I said move okay drama comedies yeah I
don't they just call them K comedies
where are we going oh my hair is caught
in your zipper I spilled all the glue on
my hand
Oh what makes a caterer I'm a romance
scene my love from another star so I'm
in June and your son young I was
diagnosed with depending too much on you
I was diagnosed with that Koreans are
more soft piano snow falling are you
drunk already are you drunk already no I
don't know women don't sit like that
like this how did I fit in Korea
everybody sit in Korea it's still
there's still women give me 15 seconds
wait let's begin keep face is so
malleable you can just like do anything
you want to it it's really like how
kissable that is over I'm blessed
alright so now we're going to actually
shoot it as if we're in the drama
why not you can't drink with a piece of
pottery you couldn't drink with a dog I
guess you couldn't even drink with a
tree are you drunk already
no not at all but I'm full of chemistry
all men go crazy for me I start a fire
in their hearts the women have chemistry
when they see me no no if you're not
drunk you should see a shrink
I already did I was diagnosed with
depending too much on you but how can
you refer to me as pottery a dog or a
tree this has never happened in my life
give me 15 seconds why 15 seconds they
call me the fairy of 15 seconds I
capture people's attention in 15 seconds
in the commercials
give me 15 seconds ready start
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm afraid of what we're going to be
it's the food of my home planet
go back to your alien planet and don't
you come back here again I'm a jewel of
jealousy just grab my face nope only
like a Stalin Shakespeare and Hamlet and
I'm just dead Oh